[Musique]
chers compatriotes il m'a fallu attendre
huit jours pour pouvoir m'adresser
directement à vous et remercier ceux
d'entre vous qui m'ont accordé leur
confiance à travers moi vous avez
exprimé un élan formidable de fierté et
de dignité française vous avez d'abord
voulu dire non à l'effacement de la
patrie à la corruption politique à
l'immigration invasion à l'injustice
sociale à l'inquiétude des jeunes et des
moins jeunes
non à la montée vertigineuse de la
violence criminelle et délinquante à
l'impuissance de l'état et aux risques
d'anarchie
quatre faits principaux marquer cette
étape vers la vraie victoire de la
france retrouver la défaite du premier
ministre jospin dont le bilan de gauche
plurielle a été désavoué le recul du
président de la république qui n'atteint
pas 20 % des suffrages exprimés ce qui
est un désaveu cinglant de sa personne
et de son action le premier a eu un
réflexe de dignité et a démissionné ce
geste le nord le second qui aussi aurait
dû le faire s'accroche décidé pour se
sauver et échapper aux juges qui
attendent la fin de son immunité
présidentielle de jeu le site tout faire
j'ai bien dit tout pour se maintenir
l'effondrement du parti communiste tombé
à 3,2 bon sens enfin le succès du
candidat du peuple français que je suis
témoignant de la volonté de changement
des citoyens les plus lucides et les
plus déterminés
le deuxième tour est un acte d'une
portée historique exceptionnel c'est
vous qui par votre bulletin de vote
allaient décider soit de continuer dans
la voie de la décadence alors hélas
devenu irréversible soin d'en sortir par
un de ces sursauts extraordinaire du
peuple qui ont à plusieurs reprises au
cours des siècles permis de sauver la
patrie du désastre et de la servitude
depuis lundi on peut assister à un
extravagant
changement de décor c'est un véritable
déferlement de calomnies un torrent de
haine des politiciens qui ont été
désavoués et n'accepte pas le verdict
des urnes
en l'espace d'une soirée je suis dénoncé
comme un danger pour la république
chirac dit même
qu'il a peur du succès du candidat du
peuple français ils essayent d'effrayer
nos concitoyens en les plaçant devant un
dilemme lui ou l'extrémisme mais la
république qu'il affirme défendre c'est
la ripoublique des camarades des copains
et des coquins complice des affaires
scandaleuses des détournements et des
trafics d'influencé pour essayer de se
sauver et d'échapper aux poursuites qui
l'attendent
ils en appellent au front populaire
contre le rassemblement national ce qui
n'est pas étonnant quand on sait qu'il a
été communiste dans sa jeunesse et qu'il
a toujours manifesté une indulgence
envers le communisme elle l'a conduit
entre autres à recevoir chez lui en
dehors de toute obligation officielle
dans son château de bity comme un ami
le chef de la chine communiste
responsable de dizaines de millions de
morts
chirac n'a d'ailleurs jamais condamné le
communisme il est donc normal
qu'aujourd'hui les communistes soient
ses alliés encore assommés par le choc
du réveil national toutes les
composantes de la gauche socialistes
communistes verts gauchistes syndicat
marc six loges maçonniques évêques
progressiste qui hier encore le traitait
de voleur et de supermenteur se sont
ralliés et appelle à voter pour lui seul
capable à leurs yeux de sauver leurs
privilèges
chirac déguisés en chevaliers blancs
avec son petit panagiotis il y a de quoi
mourir de rire
on a peine à croire que les politiciens
de gauche acceptent d'être les pantins
de cette comédie mais les ennemis de la
france française hausse le ton un jury
et menaces pis encore ils n'hésitent pas
à pousser les collégiens et les lycéens
mineurs dans la rue à hurler des seconde
guerre civile
au risque de déclencher la chienlit
comme en 1968
chirac par une pitoyable dérobade a fui
le débat télévisé traditionnels que les
électeurs attendaient ils agitent les
oripeaux dérisoire d'un facisme mort il
ya 60 ans françaises français mes chers
compatriotes il se moque de vous et vous
prennent pour des minus vous savez bien
que le pen n'a commis d'autre crime que
de dire tout haut la vérité que vous
penser tout bas ce n'est pas moi qui ait
gouverné le pays
ce sont eux jospin et chirac toutes deux
responsables
coupable d'avoir conduit la france dans
l'impasse est-ce donc criminels d'aimer
sa patrie et de la défense de se sentir
solidaire du peuple qui travaille qui
souffrent et d'exprimer sa révolte et
son espérance que vous vous soyez
abstenus ou que vous ayez voté au
premier tour le choix décisif dépend de
vous si vous préférez le déclin et la
ruine voté chirac mais si vous voulez
que cela change et que la france vive
alors votez pour moi
[Musique]